Wow!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Today is the last day for my sponsored streams for Mecha Break!
Yes!
So, if you guys didn't know, um, if you, uh, uh, there's Twitch drops right now for Mecha Break at the moment.
I'm trying to find the PNG for us.
Hahaha!
So, if you guys didn't know, um, by watching these streams, you are eligible to get a Twitch drop.
Not eligible, what's the word?
You are, you will get, not eligible, because you will get it.
Hahaha!
But, yes, you'll get a, uh, all the Catgirl accessories for your pilot, yes!
Uh, I wonder if the guys can wear this, too.
Ooh!
Hahaha!
Um, but yes, and today is the last day for this.
So, uh, I'll be doing a two-hour stream today.
Um, and on the last hour, we will be doing custom lobbies, too.
So, um, if you guys want to join in on the custom lobbies and want to play with me, um, all you have to do is exclamation point Mecha Break or click on the link that is, uh, pinned in the chat right now.
Um, download the game.
It is free to play.
For those who don't know or haven't caught the last two streams, um, Mecha Break is a free-to-play Mecha Shooter, third-person Mecha Shooter.
So, um, so, there is three different game modes.
There is Hero Shooter mode, which is a, uh, regular, uh, 6v6, uh, Mecha fight.
There is Extraction mode, and there is 3v3 Deathmatch mode.
So, if you, like, depending on what type of, like, what type of experience you want, you can choose between all three.
And, um, it comes with 12 free Mechas that you can play.
Like, 12, uh, 12, uh, different types of characters that you can play.
And there are three different roles.
There's, uh, DPS, Support, and I think, I think it's, like, Sniper, Support, and Tank.
Oh, wait, not Sniper.
What was it?
It was DPS, Support, and Tank.
So, just, like, what you see in normally, normal Hero Shooters.
But, yes!
I'll be doing my last Mecha, I don't know if it'll be my last Mecha Breakstream, but it'll be the last, um, Mecha Breakstream for this promotion, uh, for the Twitch drops.
So, let's get back into it.
Um, also, guys, I found out yesterday, um, because, you know how I got a new, uh, I got PC last year?
A new PC last year?
Um, so, I found out last year, yesterday, that I've been playing with Mouse Acceleration on this entire time.
Because I forgot to turn it off when I got my new, when I got my PC at that time.
And I never noticed, because I can't tell.
I can't tell!
Because, yeah, because, like, okay, I only found out, because I was trying to tweak some settings last night.
And then, I was, like, looking at my mouse, and it says Mouse Acceleration was on.
And I don't know how long it's been.
I don't know.
Um, yeah, because it's on as default.
And I, I can't believe I've made it so far in Marvel Rivals playing with Mouse Acceleration on.
Because, um, I've never, look, guys, I've, I've never noticed.
I don't know how people notice.
So, I can notice.
Okay, so, it's crazy.
Okay, I found out about this recently.
But, it's literally, like, like, human diff.
Like, an actual skill diff.
But, I was talking to one of my friends.
And he was, like, how did you not notice?
And I was, like, I don't know.
I don't know the difference.
I literally don't know the difference.
And then he was, like, bro, I can tell even when my DPI is off.
I mean, which is fine.
Because, you know, like, you can tell when it's faster or whatever.
But, like, this guy, um, he's, like, a pro gamer.
He's one of the, you know, I'm friends with a lot of pro players.
And, like, apparently, pro players, when they move their mouse, they can tell exactly what DPI it is.
And, like, if they have mouse acceleration on.
So, like, so, like, he would be, like, he would be, like, okay, I'm moving my mouse.
This is 600 DPI.
I'm moving my mouse.
This is 800.
So, they can tell, pro players can actually tell exactly what DPI they're playing on without having to look at it.
Like, they can pinpoint the numbers.
Like, yes, okay.
Like, and then, like, he's, like, okay, you press these buttons.
He's, like, okay, so this is my mouse.
And you press these buttons.
And I can tell, like, exactly what DPI I'm on.
And I was, like, what?
I was, like, yeah.
And he's, like, no, like, pro players know the difference.
Because we have to know the difference between, like, and then he's, like, yeah.
And I know if I have mouse acceleration on because I can feel the change in my mouse if mouse acceleration is on.
I'm, like, what the?
I was just, like, I was, like, what?
I... I didn't... I... I just... I don't know.
I don't know how they do it.
I don't... It's actually crazy.
And they can tell exactly if mouse acceleration is on or not, too.
Like, just by moving their mouse.
And, like, it's actually skill diff.
Actual... Actual skill diff for me.
No, I couldn't tell!
Being able to feel mouse acceleration is free.
No, it's not!
I can't tell!
I literally don't know!
I don't know!
I didn't know until now!
Until yesterday!
The thing is, back in Overwatch, when I got top 500 in Overwatch, I also had mouse...
Top 500 in Overwatch and Apex, I also had mouse acceleration on.
Because I didn't know.
I...
Because I would...
Every time I get a new PC, I kept... I would keep it on by default, and it would be on.
And then, like, someone else would find out for me that I had them on.
Because I always forget to check.
I always forget to check if mouse acceleration is on.
Anyway.
I'm not playing with mouse acceleration anymore.
I found that out yesterday.
So, I am a changed person.
The weights come off now.
I never check.
I always never check.
So, for those who don't know how to check.
Okay.
So, it's basically...
You go to mouse settings.
Okay.
And I...
I keep forgetting.
So, you go to mouse settings.
And it's the enhanced pointer precision.
Precision.
Precision?
I don't know how to fucking pronounce it.
Prec...
I'm pronouncing it wrong.
I don't fucking know.
So, I am...
We're tired.
Um...
But it was this.
I had...
I had this on.
This was on this entire time.
For the last year, by the way.
Uh...
This...
This was on for the last year, at least.
Uh...
Oopsie.
So, basically...
What I've...
I've been playing Marvel Rivals with this on.
I don't know how I got that far.
I really, generally don't know.
Um...
But I thought that was...
Uh...
I have to turn mine off now, too.
I told you!
You don't...
No!
It's...
You always...
You always forget.
And you're totally not turning it off right now, too.
Uh...
Yeah, I got top 500 with that on.
I've been playing...
Um...
I've been playing it with that on this entire time.
Which is absolutely fucking crazy.
I...
No way!
I see!
I told you!
It's not...
It's...
It's not something that's, like...
The first thing you do.
It's not something that I do.
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
Yeah, so...
It's actually crazy.
I was not expecting that.
I...
I thought I had...
Because I always...
I, like...
Someone will find out for me.
And then...
Um...
Because, like, I had to...
Like, they were...
Like, I was trying to fix some settings and stuff.
So I had my friend help me.
And they're like, Oh, wait.
Check your mouse settings.
And I checked my mouse settings.
And they're like, You have...
My friend was like...
I have mouse acceleration on.
I'm like...
Wait.
And then my friend was like...
How did he not know?
I...
I'm like...
What?
You know, like...
Like, that face when you're like...
Oh.
Um...
I just don't notice.
I don't notice at all.
But, like, subconsciously.
It actually, like...
Affects me subconsciously.
But, like...
Um...
I do get better when it's off.
But I definitely, like...
Uh...
I definitely, like, don't notice it.
I...
I can't tell.
Like, I...
Can't tell consciously.
But subconsciously, I do perform better with it off.
Yeah.
How do I know I get better if you don't...
It's because...
When I turn it off...
My gameplay improves.
That's like...
It's like...
Gaming 101.
I still can't believe pros can tell the...
Can, like, tell the difference.
Like...
When it's, like...
With the DPI and...
Mouse to sell.
And everything.
Like, um...
Because, like...
Okay, so...
Um...
My friend...
He was also, like...
Yeah, like...
When I'm at, like, a gaming cafe...
I would literally, like...
If there's no, like, settings for it...
On the screen...
Like, you know how, like...
Um...
Uh...
For G Pro...
They have, like...
The...
For Logitech...
They have, like, a special app for...
Like, on...
Um...
App on the PC where you can adjust your DPI...
Like...
Um...
On the app.
But then, like...
Some gaming PCs...
Apparently...
They, um...
You can only adjust it with your mouse.
So you have to press the buttons on your mouse.
So, like...
If you go...
You go in...
Assuming, like, you know...
The default...
Um...
The default, like, DPIs and stuff...
Apparently, like...
Pro players who go to...
Gaming PCs and stuff to practice for bootcamp.
They don't need the app.
They literally just press the button, feel it out, and know exactly when their DPI for it.
They'll be like, oh, okay.
800.
Like, press the button and then feel it.
Okay, that's 1,200.
Press the button and then, like, I can't tell.
I legitimately, I tried it out myself.
I, like, pressed buttons and I'd be like, okay, which is my 800 DPI?
I couldn't tell.
I got confused.
I got lost.
I was so lost trying to figure out what was my DPI.
When I'm, like, on someone, like, if I'm, like, trying to figure it out.
Yeah, I'd be so lost.
Uh, Brainy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 100 biddies.
Um, anyway.
Yeah, anyway, so...
Now I, my weights are off, so I should be a better player now, right?
Uh...
You're not... Okay, like, if it's, like, you know, 200 DPI, we're in, like, 1600.
I can tell if it's, um...
I could tell if it's, like, you know, uh, low.
But if it's, like, you know, 800 DPI versus...
What was... What's the default?
It's, like, 800, 1200.
What was it?
It's, like...
Was it 400, 800, and 1200 DPI?
Those are the three, right?
For the default ones?
Um, I can't tell for the default, usually.
Then 1600?
I can't tell between, like...
Sometimes, like...
It's hard for me to figure out which one's 400, 800, and 1600.
It's a little hard.
Cause I'm... I get, like, super confused.
I...
Like...
I, like...
I just get very confused, okay?
Cause I try to do it without, like, looking at my app.
And I, like...
I, like, throw myself into a confusion.
It's fun.
This is very fast-paced.
Just click heads.
No, this is very important.
This is very important to...
Clicking heads!
Alright.
Where's me?
Oh, I'm a baby.
Bomb ready.
That's right.
The sniper insta-lock.
We don't need...
Oh, my God.
Luminate.
Good luck.
Good luck, my Luminate player.
You'll need it.
I'm gonna be streaming two hours today.
Mhm.
Just click the head.
It'll be that easy.
Just click the head, right?
Let me in!
Of course I start...
Of course I start with my boy.
Sorry.
My hot, sexy girl.
Narukami.
That's right.
Of course I start with her.
She's my bae.
This is the third stream, actually.
Not the second.
That's right.
I like how someone's first message is like...
Sexy robot!
He's like...
This is it.
This is where she got me.
I have to contribute to this chat now.
I...
I have to talk in this chat after that.
Why does a robot need an hourglass?
Why not?
It's for aerodynamics.
You won't understand.
You're not an engineer.
You don't understand.
All my robot engineers will understand.
Exactly.
Why not?
It is for the aerodynamics, alright?
It makes robot move faster.
It's engineering robotics 101.
Fucking normies don't understand.
Basic engineering.
Oh my god.
Is this objective?
Fuck!
That was objective base.
I hate that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I guess I'll actually play as a sniper.
I need to, like, find, like, an actual sniper spot, though.
Alright.
There you go.
Oh wait.
Everybody's so far.
I see you.
That's right.
I can no-scope you.
Okay.
I actually have to get closer.
I- Everybody's so far.
I'm trying to snipe, but everyone's so far.
Oh no.
Wait, where am I?
Okay.
I'll play how it's meant to be played.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Fucking bitches.
Come on.
That's goddamn right.
I guess I'll not frontline.
I miss frontlining, though.
But frontline is so easy.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I know, I know I shouldn't frontline.
Forget frontline.
That's goddamn right.
My team will be okay.
I believe in him.
I'll just frontline.
Because I believe.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Where are they?
Oh, we should be getting the key.
Oh fuck.
God damn it.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm fucking around too much.
I don't think he knows.
There's no way he knows.
I'm frontlining.
There's no way.
They'll be like, what is this Nurukami doing?
You can't.
You don't understand me.
Here you go.
Oh, he's one.
Oh, I thought I was gonna hit that.
Nice.
Guys, please.
We have to.
My god, he's one.
No, no.
Yes.
It was worth it.
Please.
I'm the sniper.
I'm not meant to do objectives.
I'm just supposed to shoot.
That's it.
I'm mad.
Come on.
God damn.
He's so fast.
Wait, where's the key?
Please.
That's right.
Here you go.
We got it.
Guys, please.
Bye.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That was a hit.
That was insane.
Come on.
It's just one shot.
He's one shot.
Please.
Oh, I missed that.
Okay, nice.
That's good.
Why are you running?
Okay.
What's the objective now?
I don't know.
I'm just shooting now.
Here we go.
Oh.
Ace.
Wait.
Oh, you almost got me.
You almost got me.
I can hear.
That's right.
You almost got me.
But I got ears.
I heard you from behind.
I don't think I need zoom though.
Yeah, he's one hit.
Nice.
I don't think I need zoom.
Oh my god.
Please.
That's right.
I have so much free raid.
You have three of them here.
They don't lock down.
Look at me.
I'm just chilling.
There we go.
Oh my god.
I love it.
I don't have to worry.
I can just chill.
I'm just gonna have to go here.
I have to find a new sniper perch.
So that people don't come after me.
Oh no.
No, my energy.
I'm stuck.
That's good.
Come on.
No.
Nice.
I got him.
Where is he?
I know you're here.
I think just cause you're flying so fast.
I can't hit you.
You're right.
That's fine.
God dammit.
Nice.
It's fine.
I did it.
I still did it.
I still got it.
We're fine.
Logging in and focus.
He was right.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
We got it.
Plan.
Whoa.
So easy.
Oh, just cause you're fast?
Look at you, girl.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
I'm gonna send another one in here.
Huh?
You think you're just gonna get close to me?
Oh, you left.
You're scared.
You're so scared.
Easy.
So easy.
I literally had to.
Oh my God.
That was so free.
That was so fucking free.
Ignoring everything that's not on the objective.
Like...
Legitimately, all I had to do was just stand there.
And...
And just...
Oh, I haven't had a key like that in so long.
Get stopped.
I was an MVP?
What did you do?
Oh my gosh.
Top finisher.
Let's fucking go.
I had the most kill.
What did you do?
Oh, it's cause...
Oh, fucking objective whore.
Like...
Oh.
Just cause...
She did...
In a...
Just cause...
She had...
One...
She's a team player.
This is rigged.
This is so...
Rigged.
Um.
My kills enabled the team to play the objective.
What do you mean?
They play the game.
You're shaming them for you.
Um.
Because...
I deserve the MVP.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Okay?
I...
All I'm gonna say is that...
Um.
I deserve that MVP.
She could be an objective player.
But...
Um.
I should get the MVP.
Just cause...
I got the most kills.
I mean...
Caplers don't get MVP.
Alright.
Let's do 3-3.
Uh.
Alright.
Oh, whoops.
Tactical Station.
Arc Arena.
I think my favorite has to be...
Out of all the characters...
Uh.
Wait, there's missions?
I've just been...
There's missions?
I didn't realize there's missions.
Are we talking about...
Operation Storm?
Is that the mission?
Oh.
Is this mission?
What's this?
Neutralize enemies...
Is it?
No.
This is the...
This is extraction, right?
Yeah.
This is the extraction mode.
Isn't it?
Yeah.
Is the...
Are missions...
Yeah.
Are missions the...
Extraction mode?
Or do you mean the challenge?
Oh.
This one?
No.
I don't need...
Is it this?
Oh.
It's too late.
Hello, everybody.
Look at me.
My kidia...
Kidia is insane.
Alright.
I am...
Oh.
Goddammit.
I wanna play Akula.
Okay.
I am willing...
To play...
Akula...
Uh...
Not...
Norukami.
Don't worry.
I am willing to play...
Norukami.
I know...
You know...
There's...
There's so many other...
I wanted to do...
Norukami...
Or Akula.
I think they were my two mains.
I know like...
You know...
There are 12 different characters.
But like...
Not gonna lie.
Yeah...
There's 12 of them.
But for me...
There's only two fun ones for me.
Because I am not a masochist to play tank.
And...
I play support like...
Twice.
And...
Never again.
When I played support...
Um...
When I played support that one time...
And then...
Like...
Legitimately...
It was just like...
Hunting a rabbit right there.
Uh...
It was not a good time for me.
Yeah, I'm having like...
PTSD thinking about it.
It was...
It was very rough.
It was very, very rough.
I don't understand why you would put yourself through that.
Unless you're also a masochist.
I feel like it's only fun when you're in high elo.
Destroy all enemy units.
Cause like...
For me...
That shit was so fucking hard.
Holy shit.
What the fu- OH SHIT!
OH MY GOD!
YOU
FUCKING SHOOTING THERE NURUKAMI!
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
I really have a panther on my ass right now.
Like...
What was I supposed to do?
Oh, this guy.
Okay, like...
That's fucked up.
I literally had a panther on my ass.
Like, what the fuck?
Enter...
Oh my god!
I'm getting hunted.
I'm getting hunted by there.
That's fucking right.
It's not as fun too, right?
Not as fun, right?
Oh, that's right, NURUKAMI!
That's not fun, right?
Yeah, it better not be fun.
Yeah, I know.
It's not fun at all.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is so rough.
Guys.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I need help.
OH MY GOD!
You're following me!
Oh, I'm getting NURUKAMI dipped so high.
I'm getting...
Bro, I'm getting NURUKAMI dipped at the moment.
This guy is...
I'm just a baby NURUKAMI.
This guy's been playing NURUKAMI his entire life since launch.
He's been playing since goddamn launch.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
I'm trying my best to help.
Like, I have to be, like, so aware.
Right now.
Because of this stupid other NURUKAMI.
Jesus Christ.
Like, legitimately.
Oh my god.
That's right!
Revenge!
Revenge, bitch!
Oh my god.
I actually have to, like, run around all...
Like, I can't stay standstill for this.
I just noticed.
I legitimately cannot standstill.
Like, I have to, like, move around so much.
Okay.
You got what you deserve.
I actually cannot move.
I cannot, like, standstill.
Woken.
Ready to pick off some stragglers.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
No!
I literally...
The one time...
Like, when...
I have to, like...
Every time I standstill, I'm dead.
Every time...
I got hunted down so high.
Legitally.
Oh my...
Okay, we gotta do another NURUKAMI game.
I can't...
We can't do this.
This guy's been playing NURUKAMI since launch.
He's cracked the system.
He's...
He's cracked it.
Holy fuck.
Legit...
I sit still...
I get shot at.
I...
Yeah.
I just...
I had to keep moving.
I kept...
When I kept moving, I...
I was actually alive.
I was alive for more than five seconds.
It's crazy.
Oh my god.
Is that not...
I like NURUKAMI more.
Alright.
That's it.
A kitten.
Don't worry.
Wait, what?
Bitch!
Get off her!
Get off NURUKAMI right now!
What do you mean?
Get off of her!
I hate you.
Come on.
She hasn't locked in yet.
It's not fair!
If they haven't locked in yet, I should be allowed to lock in.
Like, that should be the thing.
If they haven't locked the character in, I should be able to steal it.
Yes, that's fucking right.
That's right!
Know your place!
Yeah, the fastest fingers should win.
Hahaha!
That's goddamn right.
That's right!
Know your place, Ray!
Can't believe you tried to take NURUKAMI from me.
Know your place!
Blue button!
Thank you for the...
Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Get off of NURUKAMI now or I throw!
Hahaha!
You notice people?
It's like...
Give me...
Give me X character or I'll throw.
And they were serious.
And I was too.
Hahaha!
Don't make...
Don't call my bluff.
Trying to call my bluff.
The classic.
Give NURUKAMI or I throw.
Exactly.
Oh!
He was shooting the...
He was shooting me there too.
That's crazy.
I saw it.
Oh my god!
He doesn't know.
Okay.
Alright.
I have to...
Wait until I have more camo.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That panther wants me dead.
I can tell.
Ooh.
That's right!
I'm better!
Oh!
I don't think he knows I'm here.
Hahaha!
That's why you lost it!
I was right behind you this entire time!
Oh my god.
JK, I was right behind you this entire time and you didn't know.
He shot on my decoys too.
There we go.
I helped.
Woo!
Hahaha!
I know he wanted to shoot me too.
Woo!
I think this was the real one right?
No he's not.
Oh he is the real one.
What was that?
He was the real one too!
Okay.
There we go.
He's so confused.
Look at him.
Hahaha!
I think after like what happened to me there.
I don't think he knows.
Yeah.
I think what happened to me during that last fight with the other Nurukami.
The game balanced me.
And was like you don't deserve that here.
Let me.
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
The game told me I didn't deserve that.
So they were- they got nicer to me.
Thanks guys.
I can't.
I can't see.
The game actually got nice to me.
Woo!
I don't think they know I'm here.
Hahaha!
You were safe!
Oh no!
I can't see!
I was trying to run around!
Trying to get out of it!
I couldn't see!
Run away!
It was so hard to see!
I don't know where- how to get out of the storm!
Storm!
Haha!
It hurts!
Okay.
I'm okay now.
Oh.
I see her though.
It's fine.
The guy just falsely me!
Ahaha!
That's right!
Yeah!
Catch me!
That's good.
That Nagakami knows how I felt!
The Nagakami knows exactly how I felt!
When I kept getting chased by their panther.
No fun allowed.
That's right.
Thank God SBMM balanced me back down.
Fighting Narcami as hell.
That's right.
Easy win.
Oh, I deserve that.
I fucking deserve that.
I got seven of the kills.
Let's go.
That's right.
And they try to take my Narcami.
I lost.
Sorry.
There's no way.
Alright, let's check his info.
See?
Bro, what?
Okay,
wait.
Okay, wait.
Let me check your Narcami.
Let me... Okay, that makes very sense.
1.1.
Like, bro!
I have 1.6 hours.
I'm, like, just a little bit more than you.
Bro, 5.2?
Dude has to stop.
That's sad.
That's... Oh, my God.
I got perfect 10-0.
Let's go.
The first guy was Grandmastered.
Nice.
That's right.
For whoever said they had to be bots.
No.
They...
You know, this guy... Stop.
Stop fighting!
I got perfect KDA right there.
GM3.
Look at that.
I literally beat a GM.
Look, as a Bronze 1 player, I literally beat a GM3.
I'm practically GM3 right now.
I'm, I'm...
This is more about them than about you.
Ace Arena is a different rank.
Yeah, but it doesn't matter.
It's still, like...
It's still, like, a shooter type game.
That's the thing- It's, like, it's still, like, a similar mode to...
Um, to 6v6.
It's just it's three people instead.
And then it's...
What do you mean?
I play like two hours every time!
I told you guys, ever since...
Ever since I got mouse acceleration off, I'm a different person now.
I'm actually gaming now.
Alright, let's swap to Alyssa.
I like Alyssa.
I'm not gonna do the falcon.
Falcon was so fucking dumb.
I'm not doing falcon.
Falcon was actually...
I felt like I was shooting peas at people.
Alright.
Aquila!
I wanna do...
I like Aquila.
She's fine.
I am a falcon main though.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how you...
I don't know how you exist.
I don't know.
It feels like she does like barely any damage.
And like also has so low HP.
His HP is so fucking low.
And with so little...
With so little damage in general.
I literally just fly around and annoy people.
I'm just like...
I'm just there to harass everyone.
Oh, there's two...
Aquila players.
There's one Aquila player.
JK.
There's actually one.
Alright.
We'll do...
I think I can have time for like...
One to two more...
Uh...
Random lobby matches.
And then we'll do custom lobbies after that.
But yeah, you guys wanna have a chance to play with me!
Later!
In about like 20 minutes!
I'll be doing an hour of custom lobbies.
So, um...
Um...
So, yes.
You can download the game right now.
That's pinned on my chat.
Uh...
Or do exclamation point mecha break.
And you can download the game right now for free.
It is a free to play too.
So, uh...
You don't have to pay anything extra.
Yay!
I love free stuff.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Pilot's ready.
Alright.
Here we go.
If we...
No way.
Everything comes with a price.
That's right.
Losing to me is the price.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's objective again.
Everyone loves Narakami.
I mean, she's so fun to play.
Narakami is actually so fucking fun to play.
I feel like Panther is for the people who like melee.
And then...
Narakami is the people who like DPS.
Uh...
Seize control.
Be the first to complete.
Okay.
So it's just like...
Whoever has all three objectives.
The longest.
I guess.
Aquila!
Ready to provide aerial cover.
That's me!
Try Panther.
Left stat.
That was me too.
I just...
My brain doesn't know how...
Melee works in general.
Honestly.
What was...
My abilities again?
I know this.
Okay.
Oh, it's the falcon.
Yeah, no.
This guy's fucked.
He's...
He's not gonna be playing the game.
I know it.
I mean...
He was...
Very brave.
Very, very brave of him.
For him.
Knock into that.
Wait, where's the objective?
Okay.
It's only objective.
Okay, we gotta get A.
What the fuck do you mean?
Our team hasn't grabbed a point yet!
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
My team.
Please.
Team.
Are you serious?
My team hasn't grabbed a single point yet.
I...
I'm so sad.
Please!
What have you...
What have my team been doing?
Oh!
I can't believe it.
What has my...
Oh my god.
My team has just been fighting.
We don't care.
Oh my god.
It's...
It's a...
My team's a...
My team's a frag team.
Oh, they're a frag team.
They don't care.
You got what you deserve.
They just wanna frag.
It's understandable.
Me too.
That's what I wanna do too.
Oh!
Mobility kit activated.
Oh my god.
I'm so low.
Where's my healers?
Where's Lumine?
Where the fuck is Lumine?
Oh my god.
My team is just full of fragers.
Please.
Oh my god.
Please no.
I thought...
I thought I had more people here.
But I guess not.
I lied.
Oh no.
I'm so dead.
At least I'm fragging.
At least I'm fragging, okay.
That's all I...
at least I'm fragging, guys.
I'm still alive.
I'm a believer.
Okay.
How?
Where's my team?
Oh, this is not fair.
I don't have... I don't have the heals for this.
I actually don't have the heals to do this match.
I... Team, please!
We don't all have to be at A!
Team!
Please!
We actually don't all have to be at A!
Team!
Oh, I'm dead.
You know what?
I'd rather just die, honestly.
So I can come back with full HP.
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, my God.
I think I hit him.
That's good.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Oh, my God.
Not nice.
Okay.
Please, I'm shooting him as much as I can.
Okay, nice.
I got him.
Are you serious?
Please, somebody kill her!
Oh, my God.
She dead?
Is she dead?
Oh, thank God.
How am I still?
I don't know.
Where's Luminae?
Luminae walked away!
Oh, my God.
She was there, too.
That's the worst part.
Luminae was in that fight with me.
And she just walked away.
Okay, that's so fucked up.
Oh, my God.
That's the worst part.
When, like, she was there.
The fact that Luminae was there.
Luminae, please.
I know you're still here, Luminae.
I know.
Okay.
I can't fly.
I'm not okay right now.
Where's Luminae?
Luminae, where are you?
Oh, my God, please.
Where is she?
Oh, my God, where are you?
Oh, my God.
Where is Luminae?
I don't know how that... It's been so long.
Since I felt the touch of a robot.
It's been so long.
Holy shit, it really has been.
So very nice.
Since a robot has touched me like that.
What the fuck?
What?
I'm...
That guy...
Fight back.
Okay?
He didn't fight back.
I was like, what?
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
I'm not.
Wait.
Guys, help.
Guys.
Guys, please.
I can't do this.
I need someone to capture B for me.
Please.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do.
Oh, we just win.
That's okay.
He's just chilling.
He just... He just wanted to capture.
I'm surprised we won.
Oh my god.
That started off really bad at first.
Not gonna lie.
We, like, locked in at the last second.
Thank god.
We actually locked in.
What is that?
Lumine can't patch up.
Lumine!
What does she do?
I was like... There's no fucking way.
What do you mean?
What does she do?
Oh yeah.
She healed me.
Yeah.
That... Well, thank you for healing me for 100 HP out of that 172,000.
They did more than... The fuck is this?
King, thank you with a Twitch friend.
Thank you.
Well, you lived.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
I was fucking... I was fucking... I was fucking fighting for my life.
The entire time.
Lumine carried you.
Oh my god.
I was fucking fighting to live.
What the fuck does he mean?
Oh my god.
The one time I got MPP was the Nur... Nurukami match.
Alright, what time is it?
Okay, we have... I can sneak one more in.
Alright, I'm gonna do... I'm gonna do another... Arena for... Aquila.
Aquila this time.
Alright, what I do... The first custom lobby... I wanna do... 6v6.
6v6.
All Nurukami.
I wanna know what that's like.
Can you do... Yes, you can.
You can have all...
Uh...
Uh, you can have all of the... Like, the same character.
Yeah, that's possible.
We did that with all Falcons.
It was like... It was...
Wait, is it... Can we do... Actually, can we do that in...
Uh, 6v6?
Or is it only 3v3?
Or is it only, like, 3v3 that we can do that?
Pilot proceeding...
I forgot... I forgot it was like locked in deathmatch only.
No dupes actually... No!
They took away dupes!
Oh, that was fun now.
That was so fun though when we did the...
When we did the... 3v3 all Falcons.
Okay, we'll check match settings to see if we can do dupes.
We'll check it.
Because if we can, I wanna make it all Nurukami.
No, all Falcons was held.
That was like...
That was so hard.
It's like, oops.
Um...
Aquila!
Oh my god, not this map.
Not this map.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no.
They have Nurukami too.
Wait, what?
They're not locked?
Oh, shit.
That's so weird.
Oh, maybe because he was moving so fast.
I was gonna say, did I not lock?
Very nice.
Oh my god, where was it?
Okay.
Nice.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
That's not right.
Oh, that's so scary when he does the...
The second life shit.
Second life is so scary.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, I got you.
That's right.
Oh, I got you too.
First blood.
I can tank it.
You know what?
Get him.
Oh, I was gonna do an execute.
I knew I could tank it too.
That's the thing.
That's why I went for it.
Oh, shit.
I don't know.
I can tank it again.
No.
Oh, wait.
Did he get hit?
The Falcon get hit by it.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, he's dead!
He's dead!
Idiot!
Here he comes.
I like pay attention to that map so much.
Like, I'm like so paranoid about the map.
Oh, he thinks I didn't see him.
I saw that little speck moving over there.
You think I didn't see you?
Oh, ho, ho.
Yeah, Falcon, run.
Fly directly into...
You know what?
That's right.
Get executed.
Fly directly into my scope, you idiot.
Get out of here.
Oh.
Get your ass out of here.
Two more.
Might as well give up now.
Oh, ho, ho.
That's okay, right?
Where'd he go?
Oh, we win anyway.
No kills for you.
Look at that.
Fast game.
Wait, one kill?
Who the fuck did you kill?
Because it wasn't me.
That's right.
That's me.
Aquila.
I think I'm pretty decent.
3v3.
Aquila.
Who's the one guy that died?
Who is it?
This guy?
Looney Bus?
What is he doing?
What the fuck was Looney Bus doing here?
Nice.
All right.
Time to do custom lobby, guys.
Yay!
I'm so bronze.
How do I get out of bronze?
Oh, no.
I'm heart-suck bronze.
Oh.
All right.
I can't believe it.
Your Oshi is heart-stuck bronze in this game.
All right.
We'll do a random map here.
And I'm going to try and see what we can do.
Modify squad.
Oh, is it here?
Oh, no.
Oh, no restriction.
Oh, yes.
There you go.
Oh, Narukami.
Guys.
Oh.
I want all of it.
Oh, wait.
Insufficient.
Insufficient?
There you go.
All right.
I swear to God.
If you're not Narukami, I'm kicking you.
All right.
Uh-oh.
All snipers.
What do we do?
All right, guys.
Everybody.
Narukami.
Ready to strike.
I can't believe there's one person in our squad that actually has a guy as the pilot.
Are we all ready to strike, guys?
Ready to strike.
This is going to be a light jump.
All right.
Also, guys.
To make it fair for everyone, if you have played in the custom lobbies, let other dragons have a chance to join.
I don't want to play.
What's wrong with that?
We have a DC?
Oh, that sucks.
Sucks for you.
Narukami.
Ready to strike.
All right.
Ready.
We're all ready.
Let's try Sarah's.
Let's try Sarah the tank.
Oh, my God.
Nothing will die.
All right.
Here we go.
Okay.
We all have to work together, guys.
We all have to.
Thank God it wasn't the deathmatch version.
Because I feel like that would be so fast.
Who has a falcon?
Okay.
We all gunned down the falcon, guys.
When we see, when we see the falcon, we all gunned him down.
He's not gonna live.
Guys, he's not gonna live.
When we gunned down the falcon together.
We're shooting him on sight.
Doesn't matter.
We shoot the falcon on sight, okay?
Where is he?
He has to show himself.
He has to delete it so fast.
That's crazy.
Oh, my God.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit.
Holy fuck.
Oh, my God.
Where could we be?
We're not stand still.
We got point A, though.
They can't breach the wall.
We have snipers lined up.
What do they do?
What do they...
We can't stand still.
We stand still.
We're fucked.
Oh, my God.
There's a guy right here.
I see you.
You're trying to hide.
I don't see you.
Where did he go?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
That scared me.
I know he's a rap.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
You're trying to hide.
What?
That's...
That's so scary.
Holy shit.
I got B, though.
Narukami, you're ready to strike.
Don't worry.
I'm defending it.
Oh, I have to be next to it.
Whoops.
Never mind.
Now I'm defending it.
Oh, my God.
That's crazy.
The second sniper point.
Holy shit.
Okay.
The instant kill was fucking insane.
Because we had, like, three people aiming there.
Oh.
Whoops.
That wasn't it.
Don't worry.
They don't know.
Oh, they don't.
They know.
Oh, my God.
They don't.
They're all aiming for it.
They know.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
It's the fight of the sniper.
We're all dancing around.
Oh, shit.
What?
Doesn't know.
I'm just an empty baby spider.
Baby, baby, spider.
Oh.
No no no no.
Never expected me.
They never expected me.
No it's not.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta get B now.
I made it.
I don't know how.
This is, this is crazy.
This is- it is actually such a crazy game.
It's just- oops all snipers.
There it is.
I was like, yay!
Alright, where did he shoot me from?
Look at me very slowly, just flying up.
He is the target in the world.
Oh my god.
That was such an easy target.
Alright, guys, next one.
Okay, guys, what should we do for the next one?
I want to do more duplicates.
Which one's fun?
Can we do all Falcons again?
Should we try that again, guys?
No, that's not fun.
Okay, I'll try Cera's.
Okay, I've never played Tricera's before.
So that'll be interesting.
My god.
Okay, I need camo right now.
Oh my god, I said I need camo.
Yeah, I'm gonna sit here.
I'm gonna sit here.
Okay, what's the largest map we can do on... Okay, I wanna do all Falcons again.
And then, uh... I wanna do all Falcons again.
And then we do... We do, uh... Oh my god, wait, they got two?
Wait, when did they cap two points?
And then we do, uh... And then we do all Tricera's.
And then we'll do a normal match.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
That's right, camo, baby.
Alright.
Alright, Tricera.
Oh yeah, Tricera.
I feel like... I feel like the Tricera game is gonna last forever.
Yeah, it sounds like fun.
What if they do Tricera's versus... Oh shit!
I...
Tricera's versus Falcons.
The...
What if... Wait...
The fucking turrets fly...
Alright, how fucked up...
If it's Tricera's... Tricera's versus Falcons will lose so fast.
That I rest in these Falcons.
Yeah, I feel like...
The Falcons gotta get... Falcons un-deep-deep-deep-deep-deep-deep-deep-deep.
We just need to...
Make people...
Six comedy babies.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
What just... Okay.
How do we make it fair then?
Oh shit.
I might be dead doing this.
Okay.
I need another drone.
Oh my god.
Oh fuck.
Nice.
I got you.
I got you, buddy.
Oh.
I saw you.
I saw...
Oh.
You think you're gonna...
I know you're here.
Wait.
I saw you running around here.
Where the fuck did you go?
Assist.
Okay.
Nice.
Assist.
Oh.
Tricera's versus Sky Raiders.
Woo!
Nice.
We did it.
Luminate versus Luminate.
Okay.
Tricera's versus Sky Raiders.
I never played either of them before.
Nice.
I know I'm not MVP.
I fucked around.
I'm not playing.
Alright.
Let's see.
What's the overview?
Wait, did I get any...
Am I on the board?
I'm not on the board?
I'm not on the board.
So I don't care.
Alright.
I'll make a new lobby.
Have you played already?
Let other dragons have a chance to join as well.
Okay.
Wait.
Exit room.
Alright.
Great room.
All Falcons?
Wait.
Okay.
Let's do...
I wanna do 6v6 Falcons.
What is a good...
What's the biggest map for that, guys?
What's the biggest map for 6v6 Falcons?
What's the best one?
I?
I, Mazira?
The fuck is I?
Oh, there you go.
Alright.
Here we go.
2-1-7-8-4-4.
Have you...
Um...
If you see a dragoon that's played before, rat them out to me and I'll kick them out.
For today.
Um...
The last...
The other two streams don't count.
Just for today.
Yeah, the last match is gonna be the one mech per player.
Okay.
All Falcons.
No duplic...
Is there no, like, return players?
Alright.
If anyone...
Anyone that's played before, leave.
Except for me.
Cause this is my lobby.
Alright.
All Falcons.
I love this one.
It's such a shitshow.
Falcon.
Ready to strike.
Whoops, all Falcons.
Falcon.
Ready to strike.
Hmm.
While we wait, I'm gonna get a cough drop real quick.
With my throat.
I've been yelling.
Falcon.
Ready to strike.
Alright.
I'm ready to strike.
Me when I'm Falcon and ready to strike.
Alright.
Here we go.
Forgot how Falcon works.
Cause after that 6v6, I didn't play Falcon again.
After that 3v3 last time, I didn't play Falcon again.
Cause that was so overwhelming.
That was so...
Alright.
The thing is, it was not...
Like 3v3 was like insane.
Like, I don't know how 6v6 is gonna go.
It's gonna be an actual aerial fight.
An aerial battlefield.
I don't feel it.
Alright, here we go.
We're ready to strike.
I have to play this again.
Where is the objective?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
Wait!
I got out of... I literally... I got out of... Oh my god.
I got out of like...
Oh, let's go.
Let's get him.
Get him, boys.
Get him.
Give me a sec.
I got him.
Recharge.
Give me a sec.
This falcon's got to recharge.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Crazy.
Guys, I got to recharge.
Cover me.
Oh!
I said cover me!
Guys!
Man down.
They cover you in bullets.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Okay, that guy is gaming.
What the fuck?
Falcon down.
Okay, don't worry.
Okay.
Falcon here.
The sky is ours.
Oh god.
I'm being shot at.
Team!
Don't worry, team!
What?
I was so... I had so much HP!
What happened?
Oh my god.
I... I was out of bounds.
I don't...
The sky was like, no.
I flew too close to the sun.
I can't believe it.
I actually... I didn't even notice.
I flew too close to the sun.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I actually... got sunned.
Oh my god.
Where is everybody?
Oh shit!
Guys!
Where's my team?
Oh my god.
He doesn't know.
Oh, he doesn't know.
The sky is ours.
Oh.
Guys.
Guys, team!
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Falcon here.
No!
What?
Okay.
I got 1v1 indoor.
You're crazy.
Bro, I can't get out!
Oh my god.
The outside.
Literally, my entire job is to be inside and I somehow became on outside.
Sorry, my entire job is to be outside.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I got recharged.
He doesn't know.
He don't know I'm here.
Damn.
Oh my.
I'm trying to head over.
I'm trying my best!
He's flying so much!
Look at him!
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
It's just a warfare here.
Where the fuck did he go?
Where's the key?
Oh my god.
I can't tell.
I can't tell where the key is!
Oh no.
No, I can't do that yet.
He got...
No!
He got the key!
Oh, he just kept looping!
Oh my god.
Got you.
That's why you can't run from me.
You can't run from me.
I'm literally on your tail.
On your six!
On your fucking six!
I won't rest until you're dead.
Oh shit.
Someone's on my six now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Someone's on my six!
Oh!
I gotta get up!
Woo!
That's right, loop-de-loop!
Okay, loop-de-loop!
This guy is ours!
We might be losing!
But that was a cool loop-de-loop!
Okay.
I need to like...
Oh no, he knows I'm a...
Oh no, they know!
They know!
They know I'm a grounded...
I'm a grounded play right now!
Oh no.
Oh, I'm warning!
Warning!
I can't see!
Oh, I'm leaving the combat!
So good!
I got this guy.
What's the staff?
Oh, I'm so dead.
I am so dead, though.
There's no way.
Oh, I don't know where I am.
I can't see!
Oh my god, there's upward loops!
How many loops are there?
Okay.
Wait, I could go down faster?
I'm blind, blind.
I'm blind.
Oh my god.
They don't know.
Don't know.
Surely they won't hit me, right?
Alright.
I should be okay now.
That's right.
Oh shit, not again.
Oh, I'm getting better at this, though.
I'm getting so much better at this.
Assist time!
Oh, I can see now.
I can see!
Oh, I'm going for this guy.
That's right, I'm going for you.
Oh!
Nobody can stop me!
I should head down.
I see you!
That's fucking right, we're all here for you!
Where is he?
Oh, we're all here.
I'm fucking chasing you down.
Oh shit, we're out of bounds.
I'm still going to chase you down.
I can't see, but I can fight!
I don't need to see to fight!
Oh my god.
TELL MY WIFE!
That was a cool death.
It was cool.
Alright.
Great...
Great last words.
Bro, I was like zooming.
I zoomed so hard.
I went out with a bang.
I tell my wife, I died sick as fuck.
That was an insane dogfight.
Oh shit, they got the key again.
Don't worry, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
Battle ends in 180 seconds.
Wait, where's the key?
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, I'm lost.
Oh, there it is.
Fuck!
Oh my god, he's over there now.
Bro, what the fuck?
He didn't have to?
Holy shit, they have to.
Get him, somebody get him!
Guys, please.
We all tried to shoot him!
No!
I can't believe it.
We were so close.
Oh, Falcon.
Oh, Falcon was crazy.
That was actually like an aerial battlefield.
Excuse me?
Excuse me.
Excuse.
Okay, I was gonna say.
What the fuck is your stats?
What a fucking game.
Holy shit.
No, we did, we tried, we did do all Narukami.
It was crazy.
If you got, if you got like, sighted by one person.
Um, like, you're just, like, if you get sighted by two Narukami, it was over.
Alright.
I wanna do a...
Uh...
I wanna do Payload.
Payload was fun.
Actually, no.
Uh, Operation Verge.
Which is...
Okay.
Um...
What were the three...
What were the game modes?
Okay, that, the...
Okay, we're gonna do a Tricera.
We're gonna do a death match for Tricera.
Or like, the one where like, it's kills.
Alright, I do kills for that.
Okay, well actually, what kind of map is good for Tricera?
What kind of kills are good for Tricera?
Guys.
Or what map, sorry.
What kind of map is good for Tricera?
None?
Okay, yeah, wait.
Payload.
Payload, let's do Payload.
Okay.
Which was a good Payload map?
Guys, help me pick.
Help me pick a good Payload map for him.
Yeah, we're playing Customs.
Okay.
Long minute.
Alright, get in here.
Have you played already?
Let other dragoons have a chance to join.
Um, and other dragoons will rat you up if you rejoin the lobby.
Let's see.
Any repeaters chat?
Other than me?
Because I made the lobby.
Okay, okay.
Then we'll start.
Alright.
All...
All Triceras.
Alright.
Yeah.
We snicked you out.
Alright.
All Triceras.
I don't think I've ever...
Guys.
Oh, guys.
Sorry.
We...
I remake...
Love me.
I don't own Triceras.
I can't leave!
Dude!
Wait, can I leave in-game?!
Okay, we play it out.
Play whatever.
Play whatever you want.
What?
No, I'm not good.
Play whatever.
Okay, or try Sarah.
Okay, I play whatever I want.
Wait.
Oh, shit!
No!
I didn't have a time!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I'm so fucked!
The one falcon in the sea of tribes, Sarah!
I'm so fucked!
I'm so dead!
Oh, shit!
Sorry!
Each of us has one falcon!
Wait!
Tracer!
Oh, wait!
Aquila!
Oh, shit!
Don't worry, team!
I believe in us!
We can't kill the two Aquila!
Don't worry!
I'll help!
Guys, don't worry!
Don't worry!
I'll help!
No, I'm helping.
I'm helping Wolfsy.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't know if we can win.
Guys, I'm a little scared.
I'll stay here behind my shield.
Behind my Tricero's shield.
I'll stay here.
My little Tricero's shield.
Right there.
Where did she go?
Where did Aquila go?
I saw her.
Oh, there she is.
Are we okay?
I can't tell.
What the fuck is going on?
There's so many Tricero's.
There's so...
Oh my god.
This is actually crazy.
This is...
Oh my god.
Whoops.
Oh shit.
Don't worry.
I got you.
The Falcon is here.
Oh shit.
The other Falcon is chasing me though.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Don't you get it?
No!
It's fortress v fortress right now.
This shit is crazy.
This shit.
I should've flew to my tank.
My tank would've saved me.
Tank save me!
Okay, I did not lose to my mirrorash.
I was getting fucking shot down by an Aquila before the goddamn mirror match showed up.
What the fuck is this Tricera doing on high ground?
Like, what are you doing down there?
What the fuck are you doing down there?
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Actually get me out of here.
Oh my god.
Castle!
My fortress!
Don't worry.
My fortress is gonna be here to help me.
Don't worry, I got you!
I got you!
Oh my god, the flying fortress!
Don't worry!
The flying fortress is here!
Holy shit, that shit's crazy.
Oh my god, thank god it's not, like, all... Thank god it's not all fucking, uh...
All Triceras.
Because I'd be so fucked if the enemy team was just all Triceras.
That'd be so scary.
Oh my god, my little peas.
My little peas are shooting.
How?
What is going on?
Oh my god, please.
There you go, it's fine.
I'm helping.
Helping.
I'm pretty sure I'm helping, I can't tell.
It looks like I'm helping.
I... I look...
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, I'm trying to fly.
I'm trying to fly here.
Trying to fly.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, he's still out there?
What is our other Tricera doing?
Stabilizing.
How is he still out there?
Okay.
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you.
Oh my god, I don't know how I'm getting healed.
Wait, how am I getting healed?
Oh my god, I got you.
I got you.
Oh my god, he has shield.
I don't got you.
I'm getting sniped too.
Okay.
Oh, Tricera has shield drawn?
Oh my god, what doesn't he...
What doesn't he have?
Oh my god, you stupid Aquila.
Aquila, you stupid Aquila.
I'm just walking very slowly.
I can just stay here.
It's okay.
I cannot just stay here.
I cannot just...
It's okay, I won.
Yay.
Yeah.
The snatch comes for the better.
Yay.
But at what cost?
The slowest match.
Holy shit.
That match is crazy.
We still won.
Let's go.
You're back.
Ha!
The Junkler was here.
It's...
Why is he...
Yay!
I got carried by the Junkler.
He...
Um...
Circle...
What?
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, he's real.
He's actually real.
Oh my god.
He's...
He's yonking it.
My bad.
He's...
Like...
Hello...
I'm so serious.
He...
That's actually crazy.
That is a crazy customization right there.
Alright.
Now...
Next room.
Boom.
Alright.
That's technically a tricera match, guys.
That's technically a tricera match.
Alright, this one, you can play anything you want.
This next game.
Boom!
This is already... that was already too much tricera.
Alright, this one, you can play anything you want for this.
Anything you want.
Alright, any repeaters chat?
Anyone you want to rat out?
Alright guys, if you guys want to join in this custom lobby, make sure to download the game right now.
It is free to play.
So click on the link that's in pinned on my chat or exclamation point Mecha break, guys.
And you too can join the lobby or just support the stream in general.
And if you watch enough for today, you can unlock...
Let's see, I need to get the image real fast.
You can unlock a cat girl where your twitch drops.
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to zoom in that.
So yes, this is your last chance to get your cat girl, uh, cat girl items for free.
Whoa, yeah, whoa.
Whoa, wowee.
Alright, we have...
Let me show you how much time you have.
We have 24 minutes.
So we can do like two to three of my games.
Panther, ready to strike.
Alright, I'm gonna do a... not falcon.
I'm done with falcon.
I'm gonna do...
Narukami.
Alright, you can play whatever you want, guys, for this one.
Luminate, ready to strike.
How do I do twitch?
You just have to watch the stream.
And then you get your twitch drops.
And make sure your, um...
I think it's... make sure your steam is linked to your...
Uh, to your twitch.
So you can lock it.
You play hurricane at all?
No, I'm a Narukami Aquila.
Uh, scumbag.
Um...
Yeah.
I can't... I can't... I can't melee.
And I don't like playing tank.
I know what I am.
I know... I know what I am in this world.
Uh...
I like it though.
I like the gameplay style.
A cowboy!
You're just mad.
Mad cause bad.
Seems like a guy who's been killed by a Narukami.
Alright.
Locking in.
Oh, wait.
Someone, someone's a falcon.
We gotta kill him.
Alright.
Here we go.
Haha.
I can't believe someone's playing falcon.
Wait, do we have support?
Oh, we do.
Okay, we have Illuminae.
I was gonna say...
Okay, we better have a support here.
Alright, pocket me guys.
Pocket the sniper.
That's right, no falcons allowed.
What objective is this?
It is...
Oh, is this...
Okay.
Oh no, it's this.
Oh, wait.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, I was gonna say where the fuck is.
Oh, it's this map.
Oh, it's this one.
Okay.
Oh, I don't like this map.
I'm so mad.
That was gonna be...
That was gonna be such an easy shot too.
That was gonna be such an easy shot.
Oh my god, you stupid whore.
You're such a stupid whore.
That would've been such an easy kill.
I see you.
Oh my god, you're such a whore.
Okay.
Stupid falcon.
God, someone killed a falcon.
No!
It's not fair.
No one's harassing him!
Oh my god, look at this.
Oh my god, that is so sad.
That is actually so sad.
Watch me slowly, slowly walk up.
That's actually so sad.
He waited until I got to the top.
That's so fucked up.
Wait, we have a...
No!
We have an EMT!
Aquila!
Aquila, don't wake up!
The people need you!
Aquila, no!
Wake up!
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Wake up, Aquila.
Aquila, wake up!
Goddammit, there's that falcon.
I see him too.
Oh my god.
There's the Norukami.
I see you.
That's right, they don't know.
Wait, what?
Oh, they already captured it.
Okay.
I was gonna say, what?
Spy.
Why?
I see the...
I see a falcon near me.
I fucking...
Okay, that's not falcon, but I...
I felt something behind me.
Oh, fuck.
That's right.
Fuck you, bitch.
Nice.
Oh no.
There's someone here.
Nice.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
What's he doing in the water?!
You freaks!
You goddamn freak!
There he is!
How is he still there?
Why was he there?!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I don't know why the fuck he was there, though.
Oh my god, I need to, like, move around so much.
Oh,
he's one.
He's so dumb.
Don't know.
It's stupid.
He broke right on his face, that BF.
That's right, that's what you get from being stupid.
I don't know how we got away with that, but I take those.
I take those.
No.
I don't even know.
It works, it works.
It works.
Aquila, ready to provide aerial cover.
Aquila is ready.
I'm ready.
It just works, yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I'm just shooting him so he doesn't cap it.
Holy shit.
Maybe I can grab.
Let me see if I can grab C.
Thank you.
Alright.
I know, the shield for Tricera is crazy.
That's why you guys saw I did one round.
Tricera.
I can't do another.
Oh nice, we got C, that's good.
I was like, I'm not doing another round of Tricera.
I'm sorry.
I have to come up.
Come on.
Show yourself.
You have to come out of the water someday, right?
Fucking hell.
Oh my god, fucking hell.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Of course, of course the Falcon is fine we won.
Fuck you, I hope you had fun Falcon.
Of course, there was nothing else around us.
It's okay, we won.
That's all that matters.
We did it.
All my homies hate Falcon.
It's okay, we won.
I did it.
I was part of that team.
I assisted.
Target destroyed.
All right.
We have time for, I think, one more.
All right, we make the...
All right, I want to do one deathmatch game.
All right.
Let's see, whoops.
Let's do one deathmatch.
And then, if we have time, we'll do one more Operation Verge.
All right.
I want to be Aquila.
All right, get in here.
We're deathmatching.
I'm doing my part.
All Falcon players should be taxed to Eviate.
All right, we need one more.
All right, guys.
It's Aquila time.
Give me Aquila or I throw.
Wait.
Jay Gunslinger already played?
Oh, you rat.
You rat.
Well, he has to stay now.
All right.
We got him.
We know what you are.
We know what you are, gunslinger.
From chat.
Pilot proceeding on board.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Name.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
We'll never forget.
That you're a repeat gamer.
We know.
Shame.
All right, here we go.
Shame him.
I don't know if my aim is better or not.
I don't know if my mouse is still out.
I have no idea.
All right, here we go.
Come on, I better be slightly better.
Aquila!
That's me!
Oh, no.
This is like the storm ones, too.
Is this three Falcons?
Oh, my God.
It's three Falcons.
Guys, I need help.
I need help.
Oh my god, guys, I have all three Falcons on me.
Guys, guys, I have all three Falcons on my ass right now.
It's all Falcons.
It's like... I didn't know.
What the... That's it.
Oh, that's it.
Guys, how do I swap characters?
That's it.
I... I don't... Oh, that's it.
I know what I'm first.
No.
Who's all Falcons?
Oh, that's it.
I know exactly what I'm gonna do the moment I die.
Oh my god.
I know what I'm gonna do.
Please.
Jesus Christ.
It's like trying to shoot like a fucking mosquito.
It's like actually... Okay, that's it.
I'm angry.
How do I swap characters?
I hate... That's it.
God damn it.
I forgot to get Tricera.
I still forgot.
Alright, I don't know how this is.
I thought I was gonna go Tricera.
I don't know what character this is.
I don't have Tricera.
He's so lucky.
This is a shield.
That's it.
I have a shield now.
I have a shield.
That's it.
Someone quick go try Tricera.
It's the only way.
Someone go try Tricera.
Oh no, not the storm.
They have a shield.
I...
Oh shit, I went in the storm still.
I went in the storm.
Oh, go Sega!
Go Sega everybody!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Not the Falcons there.
It's actually crazy.
Oh.
Oh my god.
This is so cringe.
They're so lucky.
They're actually so lucky.
Oh my god.
Shield.
It's shield time.
Oh my god.
They're so low!
That's it.
I'm angry.
Second life.
Bunker city containment system deactivated.
Oh my god.
I don't know how we're alive, but we're... I'm gonna take it.
Energy low.
I'm available.
Okay, it's fine.
Rebuild!
That's fucking right.
That's right!
That's fucking right!
Energy low.
Oh, you're low.
See, you're low.
Oh, I know you're low.
I know you're low.
Come on.
He's so low.
He actually is so low.
Come on.
No!
He's so low.
That's the worst part.
No.
I'm getting targeted so hard.
Where's my team?
Where was my team?
What happened to my team?
There we go.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Where are they?
Oh my god.
You're so low.
I'm gonna chase.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
We're getting it.
Oh my god.
We have our Tricera.
That's right.
Cut this out!
Tricera!
Gun- That's right!
We beat you!
That's right!
Holy shit.
I live!
The Falcon Penis is no more!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
No!
You deserve it!
The Tricera!
Clutched it for us!
Let's go!
Jesus Christ!
A million damage taken!
We take those!
We fucking take- You know what?
That was a good time to call it.
We- That match lasted so long!
That we've actually hit the- We hit the endgame.
The Falcon Menace is no more!
I-
In and out of victory!
We did it!
We've destroyed all Falcon players!
Oh my god!
The mosquitos are dead!
We swatted them down!
They said we couldn't, but we did it!
We- Alright, everyone!
Thank you all for coming!
I hope you guys enjoyed today's last Mecha Break stream!
Um...
Alright!
How many people still- Okay, if- Does anyone need- Still need drops, guys?
Does anyone have like- Okay, if- I leave the stream open for the next five to ten minutes, will you get your drop?
I can- I can leave the stream open on the ending screen for five to ten minutes- I need at least an hour?
Alright, we're not doing that.
I- I'm sorry!
Can't leave it open for- You know, if it was five to ten minutes, I would've, guys.
Sorry, I- I can't- Sorry, I cannot- I'm sorry.
I won't be- I can't go live for another two hours.
Anyway, guys.
Um, uh, thank you all for- uh, for coming, everyone.
I hope you guys had a great time watching all the Mecha Break streams this week.
Um, I hope you guys were- managed to get your drops for those who are new here.
My name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but today I was on Twitch for the Mecha Break, uh, sponsor.
Um, so yeah.
Uh, please check me out over there.
Um, you can follow me, uh, by, uh, doing exclamation point socials and, uh, follow me on Twitter if you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch.
I usually tweet out my Twitch streams.
Um, if you want to support me via other means, uh, uh, feel free to buy my merch.
I just recently had my birthday merch released on my website.
So, DokiMerch.com is a great way to support me as well.
Uh, but yes.
I hope everybody had a great time.
Um, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Cause, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Uh, bye guys.
Bye.
A little pause...